it is time yet again that we check out
the most
horrific subreddit already cursed
comments
shiver down my spine all right let's see
if we can get cancelled or not let's do
this
you only get cancelled if you laugh
right a hammerhead
head shark made from hammerheads cool
now make a sperm whale
i'd be lying if i said i wouldn't want
to see that come on my bill after
getting bit by a snake
this is a classic one i've seen this a
million times imagine your car declines
and they bring the snake back in
you can't pay snake pit we put the venom
back in
when the restaurant is small but the
owner is creative so the waiter asked if
i wanted to go
top or bottom and i think that that's
where the confusion began your honor
that's hilarious it's a sex joke get it
german youtuber oh no he always dresses
accordingly to the games he played
you might want to stay away from
wolfenstein
pro tip pro that's a sick suit though
not gonna lie
the acting was so poor that i actually
reabsorbed a load i had previously put
ah a porter for your mom
nice my mom died five years ago i can't
wait to see her again
thank you oh damn it
are you gonna sell them like you did
mine eh
cursed babies yeah why don't people sell
babies
they're free labor right i made a joke
it wasn't even funny okay someone
literally died on my flight today so we
made an emergency landing
and everyone missed the connections the
guy behind me was complaining saying how
is it an emergency
if they're already dead and i'd just
like to say that that you sir are the
devil
couldn't everyone just pretend he was
sleeping and make a surprise
face when either getting canceled or i'm
going to hell i
we got either option here when humans
were prey that's why i leave my kitchen
window drapes open
i let the birds see me scramble eggs
just so they know what i'm capable of
[ __ ] you birds you got nothing on me
you've been cryogenically frozen
reanimated and the year is now two
thousand hundred one hundred
what's the first question you asked
how's queen elizabeth
there is no queen elizabeth anymore it's
just elizabeth she gave up the throne so
she could put her immortality to good
use
raising money for charity in russian
roulette tournaments
yeah that's about right can't wait for
the future plants produce useful oxygen
then why
eat them chicken produce bad carbon
dioxide
we should eat them okay can't argue with
facts and logics
you're going to make bad carbon dioxide
let's eat them too
[Music]
no offense is keeping those two apart
reminds me of when i used to work in a
prince
oh the days that's love right there you
are not a real gamer
unless you can shove an entire nintendo
gamecube up your ass proud to be a real
gamer
always proud you know someone's tried it
right that we should fear the strong
why a man can't just pee in peace this
is why i like to bring scissors to the
restroom yeah yeah yeah
good good day women's sales billionaires
used condom impregnants
itself wins child support that's why i
eat condoms when i'm done
using them yum yum yum tasty snack
so delish god damn it people wonder why
social
distancing will never work in india this
is how he would talk with his own
all right god damn it
this is so stressful i can't do this
guys would you drink
pee for a million dollars
i would never drink pee that's
disgusting of course imagine how much
more pee i can drink with that kind of
money
technically not wrong schools we try our
best to make our students feel
comfortable in this building the
school's toilet paper
yeah that's what wiping yourself with
newspaper feels like
wipes harder no ass no [ __ ] no ass no
i never thought about it that way i know
what i must do but i don't know if i
have the strength to do
it no ass no sh
okay have a real lightsaber or save a
random
african child from starvation jesus
christ
i love democracy use the lightsaber to
end
okay okay okay liberals want spiders to
be even sexier what the [ __ ] liberals
i thought the closed captioning was
messed up but nope he actually
said that even
what's wrong with you shoot what sense
is 100 times creepier if you whisper it
you look so peaceful when you sleep
so nice to finally meet you
[Music]
in japan there are toys of kaiju giving
press conferences to apologize for
destroying cities
these are awesome i love these i want
them ah
very sorry for destroying your city and
killing
10 000 people with my nuclear breath
godzilla
or america i don't get it what am i
missing oh no
i know it's like a nuke joke but i don't
get it godzilla was originally a
metaphor for destructive power nuclear
enabled humanity as a direct result yeah
i think this is so cool about godzilla
yeah america where's the sorry huh
have they ever apologize ooh sorry
what the [ __ ] obama that's cold obama
[ __ ]
obama was the first president to tour
this site no way
you can still apologize what the [ __ ] is
this
yeah obviously they sure maybe they had
to do it
i can understand nah what the [ __ ]
am i missing something here i probably
don't know enough historical context
well what we should move on oj simpson
got my second shot go get yours a
literal murderer got his vaccine before
my elderly elderly grandmother what a
world
did your grandma rush for two thousand
yards in a single season
let's see everybody what are your
grandma done
[Laughter]
cursed old door age 150
to 200 gender unknown mood
fear
what the [ __ ] if this dude knows how the
the top of an old door let him go
that's an old door i gotta i gotta say
man
fear the striking fear in his eyes my
god
he knows what's about to happen imagine
waking in the woods
and then you hear hey vsauce michael
here how fast can you run
michael v says no i wonder if she farted
would the holes make a flute sound
probably let's get real here what is the
disturbing fact you wish you could
unlearn
oh god here we go tumors can grow teeth
i would prefer to call them children but
okay
no way teratoma is a rare type of tumor
that can contain fully developed tissues
and organs including hair
teeth ah they can grow in your balls
ah get them out i store my p there
oh unlearn it unlearn it now unlearn it
now
we forget about this this never happened
let's talk about something else uh
anyway uh
damn it it's in there damn it
don't google terra toma for the love
of god do not i'm serious it's not even
funny you will not like it
i don't know what i was expecting moving
on forget it
forget it delete from memory delete from
brain
delete it delete it now delete it
oh god it's all i see it's burning my
retina i'm
i'm taking out my eyes
why oh god why god why
oh god oh i'm sorry seif that you had to
see that as well i'll give you a heads
up on that one
my sex life my gaming life i can't look
at anything anymore my
playing mostly single player mostly
an animal companion is great okay sex
joke
okay i spent years searching for
happiness but eventually i gave up
because i realize happiness isn't
something you find it's something you
build
when you realize it's not the sun in the
final panel
it's not the sun it's
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
that's kind of cute what is in a
disturbing fact you wish you could
unlearn oh boy
i'll i'll take any other fact to
distract me what i just learned
my mom told me i have my grandma's
nipples well give them back that's
i see this this is great
why would you why would your mom say
that that's [ __ ] up dude
idea for new skins oh valerian please
that's amazing
[Laughter]
careful though some players might use it
for some other purpose
please specify i think i've seen an
anime about this
louis vuitton is selling an airplane
shaped handbag for 39
000 i'm not reading the curse comment
i'm just interested in this bag
you can use lime glazed terracotta to
make a celtic knot design
that's kind of cool let's see someone
ruin it there's a certain other pattern
here
today i discovered my husband has me in
his phone as jennifer wardman
could be worse one of my identical twins
has the other twin in his phone as
spare parts
hey that's a good joke long ago a wolf
explained to his son eat a man and you'd
be fed for a day
whimper and roll over and play dead and
he'll feed you for a lifetime
and the next day the wolf woke up to
find his boss missing
oh poor pup come on this is
jerry baldo from brazil he may look
scary but he's one of the nicest birds i
know
big bird i'm sorry but jerry balder
looks like he sells
orphans jerry baldo no
who made these and why black widow was
scheduled to drop in theaters exactly
three months from today
black would have dropped in theaters two
years ago no
no i love how pikachu is so happy he has
the power to literally kill everyone in
the hot spring
scientists say that if a giant asteroid
hasn't hadn't killed off all the
dinosaurs
intelligent dinosaurs might have evolved
in humanity's place
imagine a velociraptor opening and only
fancy stop
what we missed out on oh no one comment
and they [ __ ] us all from only fans
velociraptors
this is dumb reply to this tweet in the
next
hour and we might slide in your dms with
a surprise no one wants to see your dick
spotify
get out of here an estimated four
percent of the internet is porn
it's all porn if you had them okay all
right okay
okay this about i did survive all of
this this entire video
i disa violate i hated it i i'm only
i only did this to show what's wrong
with the world i did i don't know
help me i'll never do this again
bye bye